حسنًا ، تستعد نساء إستونيا لأنفسهن في حالة وصول النزاع مع
روسيا إلى دول البلطيق ،
ولا يخاطرن بمئات النساء ، ويتعلم الآن
عن الإسعافات الأولية للأسلحة
وتكتيكات البقاء على قيد الحياة مع التدريب الذي
توفره الحكومة ، وذلك للتأكد
من استعدادهن لأي تهديد محتمل
في  المناطق الريفية في إستونيا الشمالية تتعلم هؤلاء النساء
كيفية الاستعداد للأسوأ
إذا كنت بحاجة إلى القتال فعليًا ،
سأقاتل من سن 20 إلى 60 ، هؤلاء
هم المجندون الجدد في
منظمة الدفاع الطوعي النسائية وهي جزء من
الدفاع شبه العسكري الذي تديره الدولة في إستونيا
منذ بداية الغزو الروسي
لأوكرانيا ، ارتفعت عضوية أوكرانيا
بالفعل أكثر من 500 من أصل 2000
أرسلوا طلبًا للانضمام إلى
المنظمة ، تعد إستونيا من بين دول البلطيق التي
كانت تسيطر عليها روسيا في السابق ولكن
منذ عام 2004 كانوا أعضاء في الناتو
و
تقول رئيسة وزراء إستونيا التابعة للاتحاد الأوروبي إن
بلادها لا تشعر بأي تهديد عسكري مباشر
من الاتحاد الروسي الأوكراني
الحالي  لكن هؤلاء النساء غير
مقتنعين ، أعتقد أن
معظمنا في
البلطيق يعيشون الآن في
وضع مخيف لأنه ليس من
الطبيعي ما يحدث
وعلينا الاستعداد وأعتقد أنني
لا أستطيع الجلوس والانتظار لأرى ما إذا
حدث شيء ما  بعد ليلة شديدة البرودة قضاها في
خيام مبنية بأنفسهم ، يتعلم هؤلاء المجندون الجدد
عن البنادق والرصاص ، وكيفية
استخدام التمويه ، والتنقل في
الغابة والتواصل عبر جهاز اتصال لاسلكي
مستعدين للدفاع عن أنفسهم
وبلدهم ضد العنف الذي يأملون ألا يأتي أبدًا